WE'RE GOING TO BE A BEGINNING
SET TODAY IS SUCH A CONGESTED --
CALENDAR DAY THAT -- WILL -- BE
A STARTING NOW AND BECAUSE WE
OBVIOUSLY DON'T HAVE A QUORUM --
WE WILL HEAR PRESENTATIONS AND
TO FOR VOTES UNTIL -- UNTIL WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE
MEMBERS HERE TO TO VOTE -- BUT I
NOTICE WE ALSO DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF PRESENTERS HERE BUT IT LOOKS
LIKE COASTAL COMMISSION IS HERE --
OUR OUR MISTER AINSWORTH ARE YOU
READY.
TO PRESENT.
YOU GOT HERE BRIGHT AND EARLY SO.
WE'LL GET YOU OUT HERE BRIGHT
EARLY -- SO -- WILL BEGIN WITH
ISSUES FORTY THREE SEVENTEEN IT
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
COASTAL COMMISSION AT THE
CONCLUSION OF ALL FOUR ITEMS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN WITH
ISSUE THIRTEEN IS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I'M JACK AINSWORTH EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION ON IT WITH ME HERE
TODAY SEIZE ENHANCE MY CHIEF
DEPUTY -- WE ARE REALLY HAPPY TO
BE HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY -- TO
CONCUR WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF YOUR STAFF ON THE COASTAL
COMMISSIONS -- FOR SPRING
FINANCE LETTER ITEMS ITEMS
FOURTEEN TO SEVENTEEN ON YOUR
GENDER.
YEAH WE JUST WE DID DISCUSS ITEM
SIXTEEN EXTERNAL COUNSEL COST
WITH YOUR STAFF.
AND WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE REPOSE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE BE USED --
AS INCLUDED IN THE SPRING
FINANCE LETTER RATHER THAN THE
SUGGEST REVISED LANGUAGE BY YOUR
STAFF.
BECAUSE THE ADDITIONAL COST THAT
COULD COULD OCCUR.
MID YEAR -- WE WHEN IT'S NOT
POSSIBLE -- TO SUBMITTED BCP SO --
WE'RE ASKING FOR THE ORIGINAL
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE OF COURSE
WILL BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TO KEEP
BILL THEN WILL ALSO KEEP
LEGISLATIVE SUB.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE SURPRISED OF
AS THE YEAR PROGRESSES AND KEEP
THE COSTS TO A MINIMUM WITH
REGARD TO THOSE EXTERNAL --
ATTORNEYS COSTS.
SO WITH THAT -- THAT'S ALL I
HAVE THIS MORNING AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I DON'T HAVE ANY AND THERE'S
NOBODY ELSE HERE TO ASK
QUESTIONS -- AT NOTING THAT IT
IS -- NINE THIRTY FIVE A. M. --
AND THE SO THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON BEFORE YOU LEAVE WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ON THE
SIDE OF ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK AND WE SHOULD ALSO ASK --
IF ANYONE ELSE SO I WOULD LIKE
TO WEIGH IN ON THESE ISSUES
HELLO THERE ARE MANY FINANCE.
AT RETAILERS FROM LA OUT ON
ISSUE SIXTEEN JUST A BY -- A
NOTE FOR YOUR AND AND THE BODIES --
INFORMATION INDEED IN ADDITION
TO THIS REQUEST BEFORE YOU THERE
WAS ALSO A CURRENT YEAR
AUGMENTATION REQUEST THAT WAS
PROCESS THROUGH THE JAIL B. C.
FOR AN ADDITIONAL.
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
THIS.
RELATING TO THIS TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN LAWSUIT NOTED IN THE
AGENDA AS WELL AS NINE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND RELATED TO
THE ORIGINAL TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN LAWSUIT.
ATTORNEYS FEES THAT AS WITH MATT
NOTED HERE IN THE AGENDA SO.
JUST TO BE SURE YOU HAVE THE
FULL PICTURE OF THE MAN OF
FUNDING THERE ARE THERE ARE
CURRENT YOUR DOLLARS AS WELL
THAT HAVEN'T COME BEFORE YOU AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE BUT WERE PROCESS
THROUGH THE GBC.
THANK YOU.
AT SIR DO I GO TO PART OF
FINANCE SO IN CONCUR WITH THE
THE DRUGS COMMENT ON ISSUE
SIXTEEN THE PROPOSED REVIVED FOR
VISUAL LANGUAGE WHAT THE LIMIT
THE DEPARTMENT ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO AUGMENT THE BUDGET AND
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR.
GIVEN THERE IS SOME UNCERTAINTY
THAT TO WHAT THOUGH THE COLONEL
COST WOULD BE AND SO ARE --
PROPOSED LANGUAGE A PRIDE A
LITTLE BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY IN
CASE THERE ARE SOME ANTICIPATED
INCREASE COSTS FOR THE EXTERNAL
COUNCIL ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND TELL WITHOUT ALL ASK
AGAIN IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMET ON ISSUES. FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN OR SEVENTEEN
APPEARS TO BE NONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE PRESENTATION
WE WILL VOTE ON THIS -- SOMETIME
AFTER WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
AIR BE IS HERE I UNDERSTAND SO --
WILL.
JUMP BACK IN THE AGENDA TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
ONE GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN PLAN.
MY NOTES SAY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
YEAH WELL SAKE IF.
THERE'S HIGHER COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS THERE OUT THERE LISTENING SO
THEY'RE OUT THERE I'M SURE
MY NAME IS ET CHIANG OF A DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT
OUR REQUEST FOR INCREASED
AUTHORITY FOR LITIGATION COSTS.
SO THIS INCREASED AUTHORITY
WOULD ENSURE THAT WE HAVE ACCESS
TO SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO BOTH
PURSUE ADDITIONAL CIVIL CASES
RELATED TO VIOLATIONS OF OUR
EMISSIONS STANDARDS.
AND ALSO TO DEFEND CALIFORNIA'S
VEHICLE STANDARDS AGAINST
ATTACKS BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
SO CURRENTLY WE HAVE A DIRECT
DRAW ACCOUNT WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE OF THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
THEY CHARGE US BASED ON THE
HOURS THAT WE USE SO WE DON'T
USE ALL THE FUNDS EVERY YEAR WE
DON'T EXPEND ALL OF THAT IT ALL
DEPENDS ON HOW COMPLEX OUR CASES
ARE.
WITH A LOT OF INVOLVED A LOT OF
EXPERT WITNESSES TRAVEL WHETHER
THEY GO TO TRIAL.
AND WE'RE ASKING TO UP OR
AUTHORITY AND MILLION DOLLARS
BECAUSE WE HAVE BUMPED UP
AGAINST THAT THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'VE HAD THESE
COMPLICATED TRIALS GRANT IS
BEATING AND INCREASED COSTS FOR
TWO REASONS.
FIRST OF ALL.
WE ARE PURSUING ADDITIONAL
EMISSION STANDARDS CASES WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT THE V. VOLKSWAGEN
CASE WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE FIAT
CHRYSLER CASE.
IN THOSE CASES THE AG'S OFFICE
ACTUALLY DIDN'T CHARGE US FOR
THE LITIGATION COSTS BECAUSE
THERE IS A CONSUMER COMPONENT.
AND THE CONSUMER LAW SECTION WAS
INVOLVED AND SO THE AG'S OFFICE
ABSORB THOSE COSTS AND THEN
RECEIVED REIMBURSEMENT AS PART
OF THE SETTLEMENTS.
WE ARE WORKING TO INVESTIGATE
ADDITIONAL EMISSION CASES RIGHT
NOW.
THE CONSUMER LAW SECTION AT THE
AGES IS NOT INVOLVED SO THEY
HAVE STARTED TO CHARGES FOR
THOSE CASES.
THE SECOND REASON IS AS THIS
COMMITTEE KNOWS WE ARE CURRENTLY
ENGAGED IN A FIGHT WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OVER.
THE RIGHT OF CALIFORNIA TO SET
OUR OWN ADMISSION STANDARDS
THEY'RE TRYING TO ROLL BACK OUR
STANDARDS WHICH IS GOING TO MAKE
IT HARDER.
IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO MEET OUR
CLEAN AIR AND CLIMATE GOALS.
SO WE'VE ALREADY FILED A FREEDOM
OF INFORMATION ACT REQUEST TO
TRY TO FIND OUT WHAT LEGAL BASIS
THEY HAVE ROLLING BACK THE
STANDARDS.
AND IF AS WE EXPECTS THEY
FINALIZE A RULE TO WITHDRAW OUR
WAIVER AND THREATEN OUR
AUTHORITY.
YOU CAN THAT WE'RE GONNA SUE SO
WHERE CAN TO BE DEFENDING OUR
VEHICLE STANDARDS AND WE EX
ANTICIPATE THAT THAT'S GONNA BE
A LONG EXTENDED LITIGATION
THAT'S GONNA BE QUITE EXPENSIVE --
AS I MENTIONED AT THE BEGINNING
OF OUR REMARKS IF WE ARE LUCKY
IN OUR LITIGATION COSTS ARE LOW
WE WILL NOT USE THESE FUNDS BUT
WE DO WANT TO HAVE THE AUTHORITY
SO THAT WE CAN DEFEND OUR
STANDARDS IF WE NEED.
TO GREAT THANK YOU -- JUST
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR LA --
HAVE COMMENTS SEEING NONE --
WILL ASK IF THERE'S PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE ONE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
NO ONE APPEARS TO BE GETTING UP
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION WILL VOTE ON THIS --
AFTER WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
ISSUE TWO IS -- OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND HAZARD
ASSESSMENT [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BLOOM LINE
LAWRENCE ICE I'M DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
HAZARD ASSESSMENT AND WITH ME IS
CARL THE NECK RISKS ARE.
ACTING CHIEF COUNSEL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO WE'RE OF THE WE'RE REQUESTING
OF FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN THE GENERAL FUND.
ON GOING TO PAY FOR DEFENSE OF
CIVIL LAWSUITS BROUGHT AGAINST A
WE HAVE PRIMARILY FOR ITS
ACTIONS AS THE LEAD AGENCY FOR
THE PURPOSES OF THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND TOXIC
ENFORCEMENT.
ACT WERE OF NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX
OR PROPOSITION.
SIXTY FIVE AWAY AS A SMALL
AGENCY AND DOESN'T HAVE A
PERMANENT.
LITIGATION BUDGET COSTS FOR
DEFENSE.
OF LITIGATION AGAINST OTO WERE
HISTORICALLY COVERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S SMALL
BUDGET ALLOCATION. FOR SMALL
OFFICES -- THE BUDGET AMOUNT FOR
SMALL OFFICES IS ABOUT A
THOUSAND HOURS PER YEAR -- AND
WE HAS RECENTLY OVER THE PAST
FIVE YEARS.
EXPERIENCED A NEED FOR GREATER
LITIGATION SUPPORT -- AND
ANTICIPATES THE TREND CONTINUING.
THANK YOU -- LA -- OR DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO SEEING NONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE PRESENTATION AND WE
WILL TAKE THIS UP AFTER
ESTABLISHING.
A QUORUM I DO WANT TO MAKE IT
OUT SMITH NOW -- WITH RESPECT TO
ISSUES ELEVEN TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN UNDER -- DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION.
OF WE ARE GOING -- TO MOVE THAT
HEARING TO MAY FIRST SADLY --
THE EXECUTIVE TEAM IS ATTENDING
A FUNERAL -- OF RETIRED REGIONAL
CHIEF STAND CRAIG WHO PASSED
AWAY RECENTLY AND SO WE'VE
ACCOMMODATED -- TO OF THE
DEPARTMENT SO THAT -- THEIR
EXECUTIVE TEAM COULD -- TO
ATTEND THAT FUNERAL.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE
THREE AS SAID THE TNC HERE.
YOU HAVE JUST THE ONE ISSUE --
FOR YOUR DEPARTMENT WELCOME TO
SEE IF I COULD MORNING GERMAN
BLOOM.
ARE THE KIDS HE IS REQUESTING A
SEVEN FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
GENERAL FUND MONIES. THREE
DESIGN -- ONE SECTION OF THE
CITY OF JACKSON STORM WATER --
SYSTEM.
THERE'S A THAT'S BEEN RETROFIT --
FIGHTING BACK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DID
ANALYSIS ON THE STANDARDS
PORTRAYED ABOVE THE CITY OF
DOWNTOWN JACKSON.
FOUNDED WAS UNSTABLE.
AND THAT A COMPLETE DAM FAILURE
COULD RESULT IN UP TO FIFTEEN
FEET OF TAILINGS IN A DATING
DOWNTOWN JACKSON.
SO THE PSC -- SPRANG INTO ACTION
REQUESTED MONEY TO RETROFIT THE
DAM.
THAT MUCH OF IT IS NOW BEEN
COMPLETED.
HOWEVER THE STORMWATER SYSTEM
FOR THAT FEEDS DIRECTLY TO THE
CITY OF JACKSON STORM WATER
SYSTEM.
THE DAMS SO MUCH SYSTEM CAN
HANDLE ABOUT THREE TIMES MORE
WATER.
THAN THE CITY SYSTEM.
SO WE'RE REQUESTING FUNDS TO
REDESIGN JUST THAT ONE SECTION.
OF THE CITY OF JACKSON
STORMWATER SYSTEM.
AND ONCE WE COMPLETE THAT
REDESIGN WILL THAT REQUEST FUNDS
TO CONSTRUCT.
THANK YOU -- JUST FOR THE
EDIFICATION THE PUBLIC I THINK I
KNOW THE I KNOW THAT I KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THIS QUESTION BUT THE
CONCERN IS THAT IF THERE'S A DAM
FAILURE.
OF THE CITY OF JACKSON WILL BE
INUNDATED BY -- THE OUTFLOW FROM
THE DAM WHICH INCLUDES TAILINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN.
KEPT BEHIND THE THE DAM -- WIRE
TAILINGS A BAD THING YEAH.
YEAH.
SO THE THE TAILINGS ARE BEHIND
THE DAM -- THEY CONTAIN ELEVATED
LEVELS OF HI METALS THAT HEAVY
METALS PARDON ME MERCURY.
LEAD ARSENIC SO FAIRLY NOXIOUS
STUFF.
DTS SEE HAS REDESIGNED - A
RETROFIT FOR THE DAM TO ACTUALLY
INSURE THAT IT MEETS ALL CURRENT
STABILITY AND SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS.
PART OF THAT -- REDESIGNED
ENSURE THAT -- STORM WATER WOULD
BE DIVERTED AROUND THE SO THAT
IT WOULDN'T BUILD UP BEHIND THE
RETROFITTED DAM.
WHEN THEY DID THAT?
THEY ACTUALLY HAD TO INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF WATER COMING OUT
FROM THE DAMS STORM WATER SYSTEM.
SO THEY THEY BASICALLY
CONSTRUCTED HUGE PIPES LEADING
INTO DIRECTLY INTO THE CITY
STORMWATER SYSTEM.
THE THREAT NOW IS THAT IN A IN A
BIG STORM.
THAT.
THE DAM STORMWATER SYSTEM CAN IN
AND DAY.
THE CITY STORMWATER SYSTEM
CAUSING FLOODING POTENTIAL STATE
LIABILITY.
SO THIS REDESIGN IS TO SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM.
UNDERSTOOD ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE PRESENTATION
MORNING -- IS THERE ANY --
REPORTER OR COMMENT FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MORE LA --
VERY SHAKEN HAD NOW -- IS THERE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE NUMBER
THREE UNDER DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE PRESENTATION AND AS SOON
AS WE ESTABLISH QUORUM WILL
START TAKING SOME VOTES.
WE HAVE TWO ISSUES FOR
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION ISSUES FOUR AND FIVE
NICE TO SEE A GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS LIZ MAKER CAM THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION.
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR BEFORE YOU
TODAY IS THE DEPARTMENT'S
REQUEST FOR TO YOUR FUNDING FROM
THE STATE PARKS PROTECTION FUND
AND FOR POSITIONS FOR THE
CONTINUATION OF TO COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND PARK ACCESS
PROJECTS.
A COMMUNITY OUTREACH PILOT
PROGRAM IS AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACH TO ENGAGING UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES FROM TWO OF THE
STATE'S LARGEST URBAN POPULATION
CENTERS.
THE BAY AREA AT CANDLESTICK
STATE PARK AND LOS ANGELES STATE
HISTORIC PARK.
THIS PROJECT HAS ESTABLISHED
COMMUNITY LIAISON TO WORK WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND NONPROFIT GROUPS TO CONDUCT
OUTREACH AND ENGAGE WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. TO CREATE
CULTURALLY RELEVANT PARK
PROGRAMMING THAT INCORPORATES
THE ASSETS IN THE EXPERIENCES OF
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES AROUND THE
PARK.
OUR HISTORY AND RELEVANCY A
PILOT PROJECT IS AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACH TO IMPROVING PUBLIC
INTERPRETATION THROUGH A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
THE CURRENT PROGRAM IS THAT TO
STATE HISTORIC PARKS AND
PRESIDIO D. SANTA BARBARA AND
CAL CITRUS PARK.
IT ADDRESSES AN INCREASING
RECOGNITION OF THE NEED FOR
IMPROVED INTERPRETATION
PROGRAMMING THAT REPRESENTS THE
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE GOAL IS TO CREATE CULTURALLY
RELEVANT AND INCLUSIVE
PROGRAMMING AND IN DOING SO
PROVIDE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CIVIC DIALOGUE AND ENGAGEMENT
WITHIN THE STATE PARK SYSTEM.
SO THESE TWO PILOT PROJECTS ARE
KEY INITIATIVES IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS TO MAKE
PARK SERVICES MORE RELEVANT TO A
CONSTITUENCY THAT'S REFLECTIVE
OF CALIFORNIANS DIVERSITY.
AND I CAN TAKE QUESTIONS ON OUR
MOVE TO THE NEXT.
ONE SEEING NO QUESTIONS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA -- HAVE
NO COMMENTS IS THERE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON EITHER OF THESE ITEMS
ISSUE FOR ISSUE.
FIVE UNDER DEPART MENT OF PARKS
AND RECREATION.
WE HAVE A QUITE GROUP HERE TODAY.
THAT MEANS YOUR PRESENTATION WAS
EXTREMELY THOROUGH AND ANSWERED
ALL QUESTIONS RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YEAH AND WE
WILL GET TO THIS AFTER WE HAVE A
QUORUM HEY JOHN -- YOU DID YOU
HAVE YOUR NINE DIGIT FIVE NOW
CHAIR -- SO ISSUE NUMBER LIVE
THE COMMENTS.
THE DIFFERENCE REQUESTING THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ON THE STATE
PARK AND RECREATION FUND TO PAY
VENDOR FEES AND OTHER
MISCELLANEOUS FEES ASSOCIATED
WITH PARKING CITATION.
DEBT COLLECTION SERVICES THIS IS
NOT A NEW ACTIVITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE PROPOSAL
DOESN'T REPRESENT ANY CHANGES TO
STATE PARKS PRACTICES ARE
POLICIES -- HOWEVER RECENT
CHANGE IN OUR VENDORS HAS
AFFORDED THE DEPARTMENT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MODERNIZE THE WAY
WE COLLECT OUTSTANDING CITATION
THAT.
SO THIS PROPOSAL WILL RESULT IN
A NET INCREASE TO STATE PARK
REVENUES WHICH WOULD OFFSET ANY
OF THE EXPENDITURES.
IT ALSO SEEKS TO MAKE THESE
PAYMENTS THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT'S NORMAL SUPPORT
APPROPRIATION PROCESS INSTEAD OF
THROUGH REIMBURSEMENTS WHICH IS
MORE IN LINE WITH STATE
ACCOUNTING AND BUDGETING
PRACTICES.
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS.
THERE ARE NONE AND WE HAVE NO
REPORTS SAID -- AND IT -- IS
THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ONCE
AGAIN ON EITHER OF THESE ITEMS
SEEING NONE.
NOW I THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND TO VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED WILL MOVE ON TO
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
ISSUES SIX AND SEVEN GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING.
THIS ITEM REQUEST THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO AND FROM VARIOUS FUNDS AND TO
PERMANENT POSITION THE SCHOOL
YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY AND
ON GOING TO IMPLEMENT OUR
RECENTLY ADOPTED ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE POLICY.
IN FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THEN LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR AND COMMISSION CHAIR
GAVIN NEWSOM DIRECTED COMMISSION
STAFF TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A
COMPREHENSIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE POLICY.
AND PROVIDED FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE DURING FISCAL YEAR
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
TO BE USED FOR POLICY
DEVELOPMENT.
INCLUDING TRAINING LISTENING
SESSIONS AND OTHER COMMUNITY
OUTREACH SESSIONS THE COMMISSION
ADOPTED ITS NEW POLICY IN
DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
FUNDING FOR THE POLICY
DEVELOPMENT STAGE HAS BEEN
EXHAUSTED AND THE COMMISSION
REQUIRES ONGOING DEDICATED
STAFFING AND FUNDING. FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION.
THE COMMISSION'S NEWLY ADOPTED
POLICY DIRECTS THE COMMISSION
AND ITS STAFF TO ACTIVELY
CONSIDER THE IMPACTS OF ITS
ACTIVITIES AND PROGRAMS ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES.
WITH REGARDS TO CLIMATE CHANGE
SEA LEVEL RISE PUBLIC ACCESS AND
CONSERVATION AND RENEWABLE
ENERGY WATERFRONT REDEVELOPMENT
AND PUBLIC LAND AND RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT.
THE COMMISSION HAS ALREADY BOND
BEGAN TO INCORPORATE THESE
CONSIDERATIONS INS TO ITS DAILY
WORK AND ITS DECISIONS BUT THE
REQUESTED STAFF AND CONTRACT
FUNDING WILL PROVIDE THE
FOUNDATION. FOR A COMPREHENSIVE
AND SUSTAINABLE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE PROGRAM I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NONE.
RIGHT WHEN IT WE LIVE ON TO THE
NEXT ISSUE.
GREAT THANK YOU -- JOINING ME AS
OUR SENIOR LEAD ATTORNEY FOR THE
LITIGATION INVOLVING PLATFORM
HOLLY AND RINCON ISLAND A DE
COMMISSIONING PROJECTS -- THIS
ITEM REQUEST FOR MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND IN FISCAL
YEAR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY TO FUND LITIGATION COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH TO OIL AND GAS
DE COMMISSIONING PROJECTS.
THAT RECEIVE FUNDING OVER THE
LAST TWO FISCAL YEARS PLATFORM
HOLLY IN RINCON ISLAND.
IN THE PRIOR REQUEST THE
COMMISSION RECEIVED A HUNDRED
AND EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE FISCAL YEARS
TO PERMANENTLY SECURE AND PLUG
IN A BAND IN OIL WELLS AND
FACILITIES.
BOTH ONSHORE AND OFFSHORE AT
PLATFORM HOLLY IN RINCON ISLAND
AFTER THE RESPECTIVE LESSEES
FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY AND
DEFAULTED ON THEIR LEASE AND
STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS.
NOW THE TRUSTEE IN THE VAN ECHO --
BANKRUPTCY CASE HAS FILED SUIT
OVER THE COMMISSION'S USE OF THE
L. WORD ON SHORE FACILITY OFF
PLATFORM HOLLY WHICH THE
COMMISSION MUST STAFF AND
OPERATE TO AVOID SIGNIFICANT
THREATS TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE STATE'S
INTEREST IN SET PRECEDENTS THAT
THE COMMISSION SHOULD NOT
COMPENSATE FORMER LESSEES FOR
REJECTING THEIR STATUTORY RAPE
ENVIRONMENTAL OBLIGATIONS.
THE COMMISSION IS NOW REQUESTING
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO ENGAGE
EXPERT OUTSIDE COUNSEL.
THE REMAINING ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE REQUEST WILL
ALLOW THE COMMISSION TO COMMENCE
LITIGATION AGAINST A FORMAL GENT
FORMER GENERAL PARTNER OF THE
RING CONN ISLAND LIMITED
PARTNERSHIP. FOR THE FULL COST
OF THE RINCON ISLAND
DECOMMISSIONING MARK FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THE STATE AND
THE GENERAL FUND HAVE BORN THIS
ENTIRE COSTS AND THE COMMISSION
BELIEVES THE UNDERTAKING THIS
LITIGATION WILL SET A PRECEDENT
FOR COST RECOVERY IN FUTURE
CASES.
IN BOTH CASES THE COMMISSION HAS
COORDINATED CLOSELY WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TO
DETERMINE WHAT LITIGATION WORK
CAN BE DONE IN HOUSE.
AND HAS RECEIVED THE PROPER
APPROVALS TO SEEK OUTSIDE
COUNSEL.
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OF LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A OF LA --
REPORT JUST A SIMILAR COMMENT AS
THE COASTAL COMMISSION THERE WAS
AN ADDITIONAL THREE MILLION
DOLLARS PROVIDED IN THE CURRENT
YEAR PROCESS THROUGH THE GEL BC
SO THIS IS NOT THE WHOLE STORY.
THANK YOU -- THAT PART OF
FINANCE NO COMMENTS THE GOOD
MORNING MS RESTS WELCOME.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
EITHER OF THESE ITEMS.
SEEING NONE SOUTH EL WOOD IS
REFERENCE TO THE TOWN.
THAT -- IS ADJACENT REFERENCE TO
THAT -- OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS
RESERVOIR.
THE SOUTH EL WOULD FIELD WHICH
IS OFF SHORE AT THE CITY OF THE
LEAD AND SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
IT'S REALLY JUST AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR ME TO SAY WHY WOULD WE NAME --
ANYTHING LIKE THAT AFTER ONE OF
THE BLUES BROTHERS.
AND NICE.
NICE ADDITION.
THAT HAVING BEEN SAID THANK YOU
FOR THE PRESENTE SHERRY MUCH --
WE ARE NOW ON MY LOSING MY PLACE
HERE.
DEPARTMENT AFICIONADO.
DIRECTOR BOTTOM IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU I WANT TO ASK YOU TO PROVIDE
THE COMMITTEE WITH AN UPDATE ON
THE DEPARTMENTS IMPLEMENTATION
OF SERVICE BASED BUDGETING.
BEFORE PRESENTING YOUR OTHER
ITEMS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS STAFF.
SO.
I'D LIKE.
TO COVER THE WHO THE WHAT THE
WHERE IN THE WHY.
SO WHAT IS SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING.
IT TURNS OUT IS AN ACTUAL
BUSINESS DISCIPLINE.
SO THE CAST OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE HOLDERS OF MASTERS OF
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION DEGREES
CONSULTING FIRMS.
REALLY FOCUS ON THIS NICHE OF
APPLYING AN ANALYTICAL TOOL. TO
INSTITUTIONS TO IMPROVE THEIR
PERFORMANCE.
AND WITHIN THAT THERE'S ACTUALLY
AN EVEN NARROWER KNEES WHICH IS
BRINGING THIS MORE MODERN
THINKING ABOUT BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES THE PUBLIC ENTITIES.
SO WHEN YOU DO SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING.
YOU FOCUS ON FOR PRIMARY ASPECTS.
IN USING YOUR ANALYTICAL
FRAMEWORK.
ON TO THE INTO T. YOU'RE
REVIEWING AND SEEKING TO IMPROVE
HERE THE FOUR ASPECTS.
THE FIRST IS IT'S HEAVILY TASK
SPACE.
YOU CREATE AN ANALYTICAL
STRUCTURE. O GO DIRECTLY INTO
THE LIST OF SERVICE SPECIFIC
ACTIVITIES.
THE ENTITY PROVIDES ACTUAL
GRANULAR TASKS.
THE SECOND ASPECT IS IT'S VERY
LABOR FOCUSED.
AS YOU'RE IDENTIFYING YOUR SWEET
OF TASKS YOU'RE ALSO ASKING AND
ANSWERING YOURSELF HOW MANY
LABOR HOURS PER TASK.
AND YOUR CURRENT LABOR
EXPENDITURE PER THOSE TAX.
IN YOUR PROJECTED FUTURE NEEDS
RELATIVE TO THOSE TASKS SO
YOU'RE LOOKING YEAR LABOR HOURS.
THE THIRD ASPECT IS IT FORCES
THE ENTITY TO ORGANIZED BY
SERVICE.
YOU'VE GONE THROUGH TASK YOU'VE
GONE THROUGH LABOR HOURS AND
THEN YOU'RE PROMPTED TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT ARE YOUR CLIENTS
EXPECT TO FROM YOU WHAT ARE YOUR
CUSTOMERS.
SEEING IS THE NEEDED SERVICES IN
YOUR ORGANIZING THEN YOUR TASKS
AND LABOR HOURS.
AROUND A SERVICE CONSTRUCT AND
LASTLY YOU WILL MERGE WITH THE
TOOL THAT ACTUAL.
VISUAL AND WANTED OF TOOL THAT
ALLOWS YOU IN USUALLY TO LOOK AT
YOUR TASKS THEIR ADJUSTMENT OVER
TIME YOUR LABOR HOURS THE
CONNECTION TO TASKS.
IN YOUR ORIENTATION TOWARD
SERVICES SO THAT'S THE WHAT.
IS SERVICE BASED BUDGETING HOW
DID WE GET HERE TODAY.
WELL IT'S A SEVENTY YEAR OLD
PLUS STORY.
IT TURNS OUT A COUPLE YEARS AGO
I WAS LOOKING IN OUR FILES AND I
FOUND A NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT
REPORT FROM BOOZ ALLEN THE
NATIONAL CONSULTING FIRM.
COMMISSIONED BY THE CALIFORNIA.
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
AND THAT REPORT CONCLUDES ONE OF
THE DEPARTMENTS MAIN HURDLES
BACK IN NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT WAS
FINDING SUSTAINABLE FUND.
YOU THE LEGISLATURE HAVE AMENDED
OUR CODE AT LEAST ONCE SECTION
SEVEN TEN POINT.
FIVE AND THE CLEAR THE FOLLOWING
QUOTE THE DEPARTMENT CONTINUES
TO BE AN ADEQUATELY FUNDED.
AND MUST SECURE SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE AND RELIABLE FUNDING.
BUT THE STORY OF HOW WE GOT HERE
GOES ON BACK IN TWO THOUSAND TEN
AND ELEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX
INSTRUCTED OUR DEPARTMENT TO
CREATE A STAKEHOLDER BASED
PROCESS.
AND LOOK AT REFORM.
ITEMS FOR OUR DEPARTMENT AND OUR
SISTER COMMISSION.
THAT PROCESS PRODUCED A
STAKEHOLDER NONPARTISAN REPORT
TWENTY EIGHT RECOMMENDATIONS.
FOR REFORM OF OUR DEPARTMENT AND
OUR COMMISSION.
THEN WE HAD TO BUDGET CYCLES AT
LEAST.
IN A SUBSEQUENT SENATE BILL THAT
IS REQUIRED OUR DEPARTMENT TO
TRUE UP OUR FEES.
WITH OUR COST OF SERVICE.
AND WE'VE ENGAGED IN DIFFICULT
DISCUSSIONS AROUND AT LEAST
EIGHT SETS OF FEE INCREASES.
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN INSTRUCTED OUR
DEPARTMENT TO REPORT BACK ON
THAT EARLIER SUITE OF TWENTY
EIGHT RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND RECONVENE THE BAND OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS.
WE GOT THE GROUP BACK TOGETHER.
AND WE ISSUE TO YOU A REPORT IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
IDENTIFYING OUR PROGRESS IN ALL
THOSE TWENTY RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE KEPT THE BAND TOGETHER IN
NOVEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN DAY PROVIDED TO YOU.
A BROAD STAKEHOLDER EXPENDITURE
CONCEPT FOR OUR DEPARTMENT THAT
HAD FOUR PRONGS.
WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE TO EXPAND
CONSERVATION EFFORTS IMPROVE
HUNTING AND FISHING
OPPORTUNITIES?
INCREASE THE STABILITY AND
SERVICES WE PROVIDE FOR THE
REGULATED COMMUNITIES.
GET MORE CALIFORNIANS OUTDOORS
AND DO IT IN A CULTURALLY
RELEVANT TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
WAY.
THAT EXPENDITURE CONCEPT I
BELIEVE INFLUENCE THE BUDGET ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OUR
DEPARTMENT RECEIVED A BUDGET%
AUGMENTATION OF THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
A SPECIFIC INSTRUCTION TO
COMPLETE SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
AND TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO DO
THE SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
SO THAT'S WHAT IT IS THAT'S HOW
WE GOT HERE.
WHY ARE WE IN THE SPOT?
I BELIEVE WE'RE IN THE SPOT
BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT IS ONE OF
THE OLDEST AGENCIES AND STATE
GOVERNMENT.
NEXT YEAR ARE COMMISSION
CELEBRATES ITS ONE HUNDRED
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY.
THERE ARE MORE ANIMALS AND
PLANTS IN THIS STATE THAN ANY
OTHER STATE IN THE UNION.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
TYPES OF SPECIES.
AND OF THOSE MORE ARE FOUND NO
WHERE ELSE IN THE WORLD IN HERE.
SO THE RARENESS OF THEM IS ALSO
INCREDIBLY HOT.
WE'RE ONE OF TWENTY FIVE
BIOLOGICAL HOT SPOTS ON THE
ENTIRE PLANET FOR BIODIVERSITY.
AND WE INTERFACE WITH SO MUCH OF
THE BUSINESS AND REGULATED
COMMUNITY I BELIEVE WE PROVE
THIS THEORY OF HAVING A THRIVING
ECONOMY.
AND A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT
SIMULTANEOUSLY.
AND WE STRUGGLED. TO BUILD OUR
TRUST OUR TRANSPARENCY IN CANDOR.
AND I BELIEVE THE SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING TOOL IS OUR PATHWAY
THROUGH THOSE VALUES.
IN A BETTER POSITION WITH YOU IN
THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH AND OUR
STAKE.
SO WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIVE FOUR GAVE
US SOME SPECIFIC INSTRUCTIONS.
THIS IS THE BUDGET ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IT'S SAID BY
DECEMBER FIFTEENTH OF LAST YEAR.
WE NEED TO GET UNDER CONTRACT A
CONSULTANT TO COULD DO THIS.
WE GOT THAT DONE IN NOVEMBER SO
REMOTE THAT A SCHEDULE WE HARD
TO LLOYD. TO INTERNATIONAL FORM
KNOWN FOR THIS DISCIPLINE.
AND IT ACTUALLY TOOK OUR STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION TO A SIMILAR ENDEAVOR
SO IT'S GOT RELEVANT EXPERIENCE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
YOUR SENATE BILL ALSO TOLD US TO
FORM AN EXECUTIVE TEAM BY
DECEMBER FIFTEENTH OF LAST YEAR
CHECK.
DONE.
IT TOLD US TO FORM AN EXTERNAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE BY DECEMBER
OF LAST YEAR CHECK DONE.
IN A TOLD US TO SUBMIT A
PRELIMINARY REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT PROGRESS WE'VE
DONE THAT.
HERE THE NEXT MILESTONES.
BY APRIL FIFTEENTH OF TWENTY
TWENTY WE NEED TO HAVE COMPLETED
THE ENDEAVOR AND PROVIDE YOU A
FULL REPORT -- WITH BEGINNING
OUR OVERSIGHT.
IN THESE HEARINGS ABOUT THAT
ENDEAVOR.
EXCUSE ME BY JANUARY FIFTEENTH
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS THE
FINAL.
FULL REPORTS A MISSION AND BY
APRIL FIFTEENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE ARE TO SHOW YOU AN
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS HOW WE'VE
TAKEN THE FINDINGS OF THE REPORT.
AND BUILT THEM INTO OUR BUDGET
CHANGE PROCESS.
WE TOOK THE TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE BUDGET ACT AND DID THIS
WITH IT.
WE HARD TO AVOID.
THAT COST IS ABOUT ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
CONTRACT.
WE USE THE REMAINING FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND TO COVER A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF INTERNAL
COSTS.
SO THAT WE CAN KEEP PACE WITH
THE LAWYER.
I'VE READ DIRECTED AND AFFECT IT
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN OF
OUR BEST AND BRIGHTEST FOLKS. TO
BE EXPECTATIONS ON THIS ENDEAVOR
I'M VERY SERIOUS ABOUT THIS
BEING THE DEPARTMENTS ONE
OPPORTUNITY. TO COMPLETE OUR
EFFORT ON BUILDING TRUST
TRANSPARENCY IN CANDOR.
OUR HUNDRED FIFTEEN FOLKS HAVE
GONE THROUGH A RIGOROUS
ANALYTICAL EFFORT AND HAVE
IDENTIFIED THREE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE TASKS
WE PROVIDE TO THE PUBLIC.
NOW AS WE GO THROUGH THE
INEVITABLE ARE YOU A LUMBER OR
SPLITTER.
I THINK THAT MAY BOIL DOWN TO
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
TASKS.
BUT NONE THE LESS WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A DATA RICH.
KIND OF REVIEW AND ASSESSMENT OF
WHAT WE ACTUALLY DO.
WITH HOSTED MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS WE'VE ENGAGED OUR
EXTERNAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE OF
WHICH WE'VE PUT ABOUT EIGHTY
PEOPLE ON WE'VE LAID ALL THIS
OUT WE'RE SEEKING INPUT WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE REMAINDER OF
THIS PHASE.
I BELIEVE AS WE GO TO ABOUT THE
FALL OF THIS YEAR.
WILL COMPLETE ALL THE MAIN
ASSIGNMENTS GET THE DATA DONE
GET THE REVIEW DONE START THE
ELECTRONIC DASHBOARD GO THROUGH
ALL THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE WORK.
WHY ISSUE A AND THE REQUEST FOR
AN ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION?
LET ME PAUSE THERE I CAN EXPLAIN
THE SPRING FINANCE LETTER AS
ISSUE.
EIGHT OR FIELD ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE ON JUST THE SERVICE
BASED BUDGETING BEFORE WE GO
INTO THAT -- JUST QUICK QUESTION
I VIEW OF YOU CAN INDULGE OUR
SHARES SO SHOULD SOME LIGHT INTO
THE WHAT THE INITIAL FINDINGS
ARE.
A WHAT WHAT DELAYED HAS HAS --
INDICATED OR FOUND AMONGST YOUR
THIS REVIEW YES.
THIS IS MY TRANSLATION OF WHAT
I'M SEEING AS DIRECTOR I'M
MAKING SURE I PERSONALLY
INVOLVED ON A WEEKLY BASIS
[inaudible]
I SEE. THREE MAIN TAKEAWAYS FOR
ME SO FAR FIRST.
I THINK THE DELOITTE PROCESS HAS.
FORCED US TO STOP THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE IDENTIFY OURSELVES.
WITHIN THE BUREAUCRACY OF OUR
DEPARTMENT.
BUT RATHER ASK OUR CUSTOMERS AND
CLIENTS.
HOW THEY THINK WE SHOULD
IDENTIFY OURSELVES SO IT'S
HELPED US SHIFT OUR FOCUS FROM
INTERNAL? TO EXTERNAL.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE TASKS IS
DEFINING YOUR SERVICES.
CONNECTED TO YOUR LABOR HOURS.
NOT AS WE SEE IT.
BUT AS OUR CUSTOMERS SO I THINK
THAT'S BEEN INCREDIBLY VALUABLE
SECOND.
I THINK IT'S ALLOWED US TO LOOK
THROUGH THREE THOUSAND PLUS
ITEMS.
AND IS THE BEGINNING OF THE
DISCUSSION ARE SOME OF THOSE
NECESSARY ARE THEY RELEVANT.
ARE THEY REDUNDANT ARE THERE
EFFICIENCIES TO BE HAD WITHIN
THAT SORTING OF TASKS.
AND THEN LASTLY I'D SAY.
AND THIS SURPRISE ME FRANKLY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG.
I THOUGHT I WOULD FACE MORE
INTERNAL RESISTANCE AND ACTUALLY
IN THAT CAST OF ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FOLKS I'M FINDING IT
IS YES.
AN ABILITY TO USE A TOOL.
AND ACTUALLY COME OUT WITH A
PRODUCT THAT WILL HELP OUR STAFF
IN THEIR DAILY LIVES.
BECAUSE THE TOOL WOULD BE USABLE
REGULARLY UPDATED ANNUALLY IS
ACTUALLY A DIGITAL PASSPORT THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO LOOK AT ALL THIS
QUANTIFICATION.
SO OWES THE THREE MAIN THINGS I
SEE SO FAR.
SO HE I'M SORRY.
NOW THAT CLEARS ISSUE A ISSUE
EIGHT IS OUR REQUESTS THROUGH
SPRING FINANCE LETTER FOR A ONE
TIME AUGMENTATION OF TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
LICENSE PLATE FUND [inaudible]
TO ALLOW US TO COMPLETE WHAT WE
CALL PHASE.
TWO I TELL YOU TODAY THAT WE
WILL GO THROUGH THIS FALL.
AND COMPLETE ALL OF THE LARGE
BODY OF WORK.
BUT A MORE IN POURTANT TASK MAY
EMERGING FACE.
TO AFTER WE'RE DONE WITH THAT I
THINK.
THE LONG RUN SUCCESS IS
[inaudible]
DEPENDED ON ME EDUCATING THREE
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
WHY THIS IS THE RIGHT TOOL? TO
USE FOR OUR FUTURE.
EDUCATING THE PUBLIC HOW TO
CONSISTENTLY USE IT.
AND TRAINING ALL THESE
CONSTITUENTS AND OUR OWN BODY OF
EMPLOYEES.
WE LEARN FROM THE PARKS
EXPERIENCE WITH A FEW DEEP
BRIEFINGS WITH THEM.
AND THEY HAD A SIGNIFICANT BODY
OF WORK WHICH WAS ABOUT.
MAKING THE TOOL A WAY OF LIFE.
AND THIS TWO MILLION DOLLARS WE
SEEK TO THE SPRING FINANCE
LETTER ALLOWS US TO COMPLEX THAT
SUBSEQUENT PHASE.
TWO MR FUNG HAS QUESTION JUST --
TO TO TO DELVE INTO THAT.
WHAT GOES INTO THIS --
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY TOOL
AGAIN CAN YOU SHED SOME LIGHT ON
THAT YES AND LET ME JUST FIRST
SAY.
I AM.
I HAVE A COMMON PERSON
UNDERSTANDING OF SOME OF THE
TECHNOLOGY BUT I'M NOT THE
TECHNOLOGY EXPERT.
UNDER OUR CURRENT PHASE ONE
CONTRACT IN FUNDING WE WILL
ACTUALLY DEVELOP AN ANALYTICAL
TOOL IT'S KIND OF A IT'S GOT
ALGORITHMS AS GOT A DATABASE AND
ITS SEARCHABLE -- THROUGH
DIFFERENT INPUTS.
AND THEN IT WILL.
DISPLAY IN A PUBLIC OUT FACING
WAY.
PIE CHARTS AND BAR GRAPHS IT'LL
ALLOW YOU US OUR CONSTITUENTS.
TO ZOOM IN AT REGION OR LAND
FACILITY LEVEL UNDERSTAND THE
TASKS RELATED TO WHATEVER YOU'RE
SEARCHING.
THE PROJECTED NEED YOU KNOW THE
UP THE IDEAL VERSION OF THE
MISSION VERSES THE CURRENT.
THAT'S THE TOOL WE EXPECT TO
EMERGE IN THE FALL WITH.
WE MADE A STRATEGIC DECISION.
DO WE HAVE THE CAPACITY
INTERNALLY TO DEVELOP THE WE DID
A LOT OF CONVERSATION WITH THE
PARKS DEPARTMENT DETERMINED
WHETHER WE COULD USE THEIR
FORMAT.
AND ADAPTED TO US RATHER THAN
GOING OUT FOR HIGHER WE MADE
THAT CHOICE.
IT'S PROVING OUT TO BE A SOLID
CHOICE.
BUT FACE.
TO THE TWO MILLION DOLLARS WE
NOW SEE IS ABOUT REALLY.
MAKING SURE THREE THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES KNOW HOW TO USE THAT
THING.
WELCOME THAT THING USE THAT
THING IT BECOMES PART OF OUR
STANDARD PRACTICE FOR BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS.
THE MATERIALS WE MIGHT APPEAR
WITH YOU AS WE DISCUSS FUTURE
BUDGET.
THAT'S A WINNING OF THE HEARTS
AND MINDS AND IT ACTUALLY MAY BE
HARDER IN THE LONG RUN THAN SOME
OF THE DATA ANALYTICS SO THIS IS
THE TOOL EXISTS RIGHT CURRENTLY
OR IS THAT BEING DEVELOPED.
IT'S AN ITERATIVE STAGES IT'S
NOT FINAL AND IT'S NOT IN THE
PHASE WERE READY TO SHARE.
BUT I DO THINK THAT'S A
MILESTONE MOMENT WHEN WE CAN
SHORT START TO GIVE PEOPLE A
CHANCE TO TEST DRIVE IT.
BUDGET IN AND IN AND IN TERMS OF
THE BUDGET REQUEST DOES THAT
COMPLETE THE WHOLE THING OR IS
THIS.
YEAH BECAUSE I WAS ONE TIME SO
THE JUSTICE TO THE TWO MAIN.
TWENTY YES EVERYTHING THE THE
THE ID TOOL AS WELL AS THE
TRAINING AND AND THE SECOND
PHASE YES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANKS RECORD YOU WANT TO MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NINE GO OUT WE HAVE
IN LA -- COME JUST A QUICK
COMMENT WE'VE BEEN REALLY
ENCOURAGED BY THE PROGRESS AND
COMMUNICATION OF THE DEPARTMENT --
AND THE ENTHUSIASM OF DONE GREAT
OUT REACH LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND
THE PUBLIC AND EVEN THOUGH THIS
WAS NOT SOMETHING THAT WAS
INITIATED BY THE DEPARTMENT AS
IT WAS A LEGISLATIVE THAT
THEY'VE REALLY EMBRACED IT AND
I'M.
AND ARE ARE KIND OF ALL IN AT
THIS POINT SO WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
IT WILL YIELD A POSITIVE TOOL
FOR ALL OF US TO USE.
GREAT GOOD TO HEAR.
ISSUE NINE ISSUE NINE I THINK IS.
VERY SIMPLE.
WE HAVE A SPRING FINANCE LETTER
IN FRONT OF YOU TO RELY ON
CERTAIN DEDICATED ACCOUNTS.
WITHIN OUR MOST MAJOR KIND OF
META META FUND WHICH IS THE
FISHING GAME PRESERVATION FUND.
BY THE WAY THAT'S BEEN AROUND I
BELIEVE SINCE NINETEEN OH NINE
SO IT'SONE OF THE OLDEST
ACCOUNT SINCE THE STATE.
FISCAL SYSTEMS.
AND OVERALL WHAT WE SEEK IS.
A MOVEMENT OF TWO POINT TWO FOUR
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS OF
AUTHORITY TO MATCH REVENUE.
SO MOVING MONEY AROUND WITHIN
THE FUN THIS ALLOWS OUR PROGRAMS
WERE REVENUE IS OUTPACING
AUTHORITY. TO FIND EQUILIBRIUM
AND CONVERSELY WHERE -- REVENUE.
IS LESS THAN IT ALREADY BRINGING
AUTHORITY DOWN AND IT KEEPS US
MATCHED ACROSS ALL THE VARIOUS
DEDICATED ACCOUNTS WITHIN THE
LARGER FISHING GAME PRESERVATION
FUND [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ISSUE TEN TEN FINALISTS I'M
SORRY.
YOU CAN YOU CAN GO ON SO ISSUE
TEN IS ABOUT.
OUR FAVORITE ANIMAL YES.
AND IT OUR LAST SUBCOMMITTEE
MEETING YOU APPROVED OUR BUDGET
PROPOSAL ON THE SIDE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENED SINCE THEN.
WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD SUCCESS GOOD
NEWS WE'VE BEEN FUND RAISING
FROM OTHER SOURCES.
SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE AN EVEN
LARGER ENDEAVOR IN A CONCERTED
WAY.
AND WE RECENTLY RECEIVED A GRANT
FROM THE SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN
DELTA CONSERVANCY.
AND WHAT WE ARE DOING TODAY IN
ISSUE TEN IS A SPRING FINANCIAL
AT A REQUEST.
THAT WOULD INCREASE OUR
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY OVER
THREE YEARS BY THE AMOUNT OF
THAT GROUND WHICH I BELIEVE IS
NINE POINT THREE A FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS.
THAT SAID I COULD HEAR YOU
CONTINUING TO REACH OUT TO OTHER
POTENTIAL YES SOURCES FOR
FUNDING US FEDERAL STATE PUBLIC
PRIVATE.
GREAT GREAT THANK YOU -- IS
THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUES EIGHT NINE OR TEN PLEASE.
AND WHILE YOU'RE STEPPING
FORWARD I'LL ASK THE SERGEANT
AFTER ADJUSTING THE MICROPHONE.
UP TO START CALLING THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BECAUSE WE'RE GETTING
PRETTY CLOSE TO THE TIME WHEN WE
WILL HAVE COMPLETED.
ALL OF OUR ITEMS.
IN RECORD TIME GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF A
QUICK -- JENNIFER FEARING HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF DEFENDERS OF%
WILDLIFE IN THE MOUNTAIN LINE
FOUNDATION AND SORT OF LOOSELY
ON BEHALF I THINK SPEAK OF
NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDER
ORGANIZATIONS ASSOCIATE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THAT HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED SINCE THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS AND THE VISION EFFORT
AND MORE RECENTLY IN THIS.
EFFORT AND I WOULD JUST SECOND
AND MS EHLERS COMMENTS ABOUT AND
BEING GRATEFUL TO ALL OF THE
INCREASING ENTHUSIASM WE HAVE
BEEN ENGAGED A STAKEHOLDERS
NUMEROUS TIMES AND IT FEELS LIKE
A VERY OPEN TRANSPARENT POSITIVE
PROCESS AND WE'RE EXCITED --
ABOUTTHE INFLECTION POINT THAT
THIS COULD BE FOR THIS AGENCIES
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
STEVE BAKER WITH THEIR NEED
ASSISTANCE FOR THE MONTEREY BAY
AQUARIUM IN SUPPORT OF THE
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING THINGS.
THANK YOU.
LUCAS FOR X. ABOUT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT OF THE
SAME THING -- BUT ALSO WOULD
JUST SAY LOOK NO FURTHER THAN
THE EXAMPLE THE STATE PARKS
DEPARTMENT WHICH ALSO UNDERWENT
A SIMILAR PROCESS OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
AND IT'S WORKED WONDERS FOR THEM
AND THIS IS MONEY WELL SPENT
THANKS VERY MUCH.
MORE MISTER CHAIRMAN ROY GROWTH
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION AS A
DEBORAH BONHAM IS POINTED OUT
NUMEROUS TIMES DEPARTMENT IS
EXTREMELY OVER TASK IN UNDER
FUNDED.
THIS IS A GREAT STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION HELPED HIM GET
THAT WORKED OUT THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR HE OR
PRESENTATIONS DIRECTOR BOTTOM --
WE'LL GET TO A VOTE HI SHELLEY I
LIVE WITH THE SERGEANT AT ARMS --
BRIEF HAND OUT FOR MEMBERS ABOUT
THE SERVICE BUT JOHN TRUCK THANK
YOU -- AS I ANNOUNCED EARLIER WE
ARE MOVING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
ITEMS TO MAY FIRST SO THAT TO
THE EXECUTIVE TEAM CAN.
ATTEND A FUNERAL TODAY.
ARE WE HAVE ALREADY HANDLED
ISSUES FOURTEEN THROUGH
SEVENTEEN OR AT LEAST HEARD THE
OF A PROPOSALS.
AND SO OUR LAST -- DEPARTMENT IS
THE STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY WE
HAVE ISSUES EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN GOOD MORNING
[inaudible]
MORNING -- I'LL START WITH ISSUE.
EIGHTEEN A SMALL CHIEF DEPUTY IS
STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY -- FOR
A SMALL AGENCY THAT BECAUSE THE
CONSERVANCY HAS A FAIRLY COMPLEX
SUPPORT BUDGET WE HAVE ABOUT.
THIRTEEN FUNDING SOURCES AT AND
THE COMING BUDGET YEAR.
AND AS DESCRIBED IN THE ANALYSIS
OUR BUDGET HAS HISTORICALLY
RELIED ON THE CONSERVANCY FIND.
AND BOND FUNDS FOR MOST OF OUR
OUR STATE OPERATIONS THE
CONSERVANCY FUND IS A SHRINKING
FIND AND THE BOND FUNDS OF
COURSE ARE LIMITED AND
RESTRICTED.
SO THE PROPOSED BUDGET WOULD
INCREASE OUR PROP ONE SUPPORT
FUNDS TO SUPPORT OUR PROBLEM
GRANT PROGRAM WE'RE CURRENTLY
MANAGING ABOUT NINETY PROP ONE
GRANTS.
WE HAVE MADE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
ABOUT 60% OF OUR PROP ONE FUNDS
AND WE HAVE A CURRENT GRANT
ROUND THAT WILL BRING IN
PROPOSALS AT THE END OF THIS
MONTH.
AT THE INCREASE IN THE MINIMUM A
LICENSE PLATE FIND IS PART OF A
LONG TERM STRATEGY TO OBTAIN
STABLE AND RESTRICTED BASELINE
FUNDING. FOR THE CONSERVANCY I'M
AND THE OVER OVERALL TOTAL
SUPPORT BUDGET IS SLIGHTLY LESS
IN.
THE COMING YEAR THAN IT IS THIS
CURRENT YEAR.
AND WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WHY DON'T YOU MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NINETEENTH PLEASE
OKAY SO I PROVIDED -- WITH THE
SERGEANT A BROCHURE. FOR THE
COAST OVERNIGHT PROGRAM THIS IS
THE PROGRAM THAT WAS CREATED
WITH AB TWO FIFTY THE LOWER COST
COASTAL ACCOMMODATIONS PROGRAM.
I'M IT THAT PROGRAM DIRECTED THE
CONSERVANCY TO COMPLETE AN
ASSESSMENT -- THAT ASSESSMENT
WAS COMPLETED IN MARCH PROP
SIXTY EIGHT INCLUDED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY TO FIND OUT THE
LOWER COST OVERNIGHT
ACCOMMODATION PROGRAM.
AND THE BUDGET PROPOSAL WOULD BE
AN INITIAL -- INITIAL FUNDING TO
START FINDING THOSE PROJECTS.
WHAT KIND OF RESULTS YOU GET FOR
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS WOULD YOU
ANTICIPATE -- DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
MUCH MONEY GIVEN YEAH WELL I
WILL HAVE THE SEAT THERE'S
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY THERE'S
ANOTHER THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR STATE PARKS TO FIND.
LOWERCOST COASTAL
ACCOMMODATIONS IN STATE PARKS I
THINK IT REALLY DEPENDS ON
WHETHER WE'RE BUILDING NEW
FACILITIES.
OR ADDING ON AND I DON'T I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE A SPECIFIC ANSWER
OF HOW MANY UNITS WE THINK WE'LL
GET FOR THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS --
BUT WE CAN GET BACK TO YOU YOU
JUST CHECK WELL ONE PROJECT --
THAT I'M FAMILIAR WITH AND IN IN
MY DISTRICT THAT THE BANK --
BRANCH MOTEL I THINK IS -- ON
PCH WHICH HAS BEEN SITTING THERE.
FOR THE DETERIORATING FOR
PROBABLY THIRTY YEARS OR SO.
MIKE RIGHT IN THAT YEAH -- THAT
THE STATE PARK PROJECT BUT I
THAT SOUNDS ABOUT RIGHT AND I
KNOW THAT THAT ONE ALONE WILL BE
FAIRLY EXPENSIVE AT THE HISTORIC.
PROPERTY SO THE RENOVATIONS ARE
GONNA ARE GONNA BE COMPLICATED --
BUT ALSO A GREAT OPPORTUNITY IN
TERMS OF ITS LOCATION IT WOULD
BE NICE TO HAVE A ROAD MAP FOR
PROJECTS LIKE THAT -- SO THAT WE
CAN PERHAPS FOCUS SOME ENERGY ON
GETTING -- GETTING THOSE FUNDED
BECAUSE IT DOES SEEM LIKE A
TRICKLE OF MONEY -- AND AND THE
TIMELINE FOR REALLY DOING SOME
GOOD ON THIS ISSUE.
IF WE IF WE WERE TO THINK ABOUT
IT IN THE CONTEXT OF THE MONIES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE.
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE A HUNDRED
YEAR PRO CRAP.
WE CERTAINLY DON'T THINK IT'S A
HUNDRED YEAR PROGRAM AND THAT
WILL PROVIDE YOUR OFFICE WITH
THE ACTUAL ASSESSMENT BECAUSE
THAT IDENTIFIED BOTH SORT OF
SHORT TERM PRIORITIES AND LONGER
TERM PRIORITY PROJECTS.
WORKING WITH THE LANDOWNERS
STUFF WHO'S WILLING AND AND KIND
OF HOW FAR ALONG ARE THOSE
PROJECTS SO I WE THINK THERE'S
PROJECTS THAT ARE READY TO GO
AND AND THEN SOME THAT ARE GOING
TO REQUIRE MORE DEVELOPMENT.
GREAT IS THERE -- ANY COMMENT
FROM LA -- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
WHAT ABOUT PUBLIC COMMENT ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THESE TWO
ITEMS?
AND THEN THE SMALL THE FLOOR IS
GOING TO BE YOURS YOU CAN JUST
TALK TO US ABOUT WHAT EVERY NOT
YOUR WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
MEMBERS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JAMIE GO ON BEHALF OF A SOUL
LATINO OUTDOORS AND THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY JUST WANTED
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR ITEM
NINETEEN AND THE APPROPRIATION
TO THE LOWER COST COASTAL
COMPETITION PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELL THAT LEFT US WITH
A LITTLE BIT OF EXTRA TIME TO
SMALLER THERE ANY PROJECTS THAT
HAVE.
URBAN CITY THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR US.
I THOUGHT I WAS GIVEN DIRECTION
TO BE SUPER SUPER FURRY IF.
WELL I'M NOT GIVING YOU DIRECT
NO NO NO THE YEAH.
NOT AT THIS TIME -- HER.
EIGHT ALL RIGHT WELL -- THANK
YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION AND WE
WILL -- WAIT FOR A TO CORRAL AT
LEAST.
ONE MORE MEMBER IN THE WILL
BEGIN VOTING.
WE NEED TO GET A BIGGER POSTED
NO
.
UP WHY DON'T I GIVE -- SINCE WE
TOOK THINGS OUT OF ORDER IF --
THERE'S ANYBODY WHO DIDN'T GET
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT TO
EARLIER -- FOR EXAMPLE WE TOOK
THE COASTAL COMMISSION FIRST
INSTEAD OF A FURTHER ON IN THE
AGENDA IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK TO ANY ITEM ON
THE AGENDA.
OF ME HAVE THIS UNUSUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH AND NOW.
WELL OKAY THAT WAS NOT
PRODUCTIVE.
ANYBODY HAVE ANY GOOD JOKES THAT
WANTED
.
TO IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
MEMBERS ARE ON THEIR WAY IF THEY
DON'T SHOW UP -- WITHIN A
REASONABLY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
WILL BE DEPUTISING THE SERGEANTS.
TO TAKE FURTHER ACTION.
WHICH I WILL NOT SPECIFY AT THIS
TIME [inaudible]
NO
.
ALL RIGHT WELL -- OF FOLKS THANK
YOU FOR BEING PATIENT -- WE ARE --
SHORT BY A MEMBER WHO --
UNFORTUNATELY AS AN EMERGENCY --
AND SO WE ARE GOING TO DO A
TRUNCATED VERSION OF OF VOTES
AND PUSH SOME ITEMS OFF TO A
FUTURE MEETING BUT LET ME ASK
FIRST IF THERE IS -- A MOTION ON
THE VOTE ONLY COUNT -- WE HAVE
TO STOP SCORE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OFFER KEEP IN MAY --
ON TRACK HERE -- LET'S TAKE A
ROLL CALL BLOOM.
HERE FONG GARCIA MULLIN
PATTERSON.
RAY S..
REVERSED.
NOW IS THERE A MOTION ON PHOTO
TO VOTE ONLY ITEMS. ONE THROUGH.
ELEVEN THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND
SIXTEEN BLOOM I FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON.
RADIUS.
REVERSE.
AND NOW ON ITEMS TO BE HEARD --
DO I HEAR A MOTION ON ISSUES
THREE FOUR AND FIVE SEVEN EIGHT
NINE AND TEN HOLD ON FORT
[inaudible] FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN I
APPRECIATE YOUR ENTHUSIASM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
HI FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON.
RAY YES.
REVERSE.
AND THAT PASSES SO THAT WE ARE
GOING -- TO A VOTE ON ITEMS SO
VOTE ONLY ITEM TWELVE VOTE ONLY
ITEM -- FIFTEEN ITEMS TO BE
HEARD ISSUES. ONE SIXTEEN ONE
SIX SIXTEEN TWO AND SEVENTEEN AT
A FUTURE MEETING. THIRTY THEY
WANT ME TO REPEAT THAT IF YOU'RE
TAKING NOTES OUT THERE I'LL LET
ME READ THROUGH IT AGAIN -- VOTE
ONLY ITEMS TWELVE AND FIFTEEN
ITEMS TO BE HEARD.
ISSUES. ONE SIX SIXTEEN TWO AND
SEVENTEEN FOR THOSE ARE OUT OF
ORDER. ONE TWO SIX SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN EVERYBODY GOT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
ADJOURNED